in our morning rounds new concerns about
the flu season US health officials say
there are signs that this may be a rough
winter confirmed flu cases at just over
7,000 are more than double what they
were this time last year the virus is
now widespread in four states the
dominant strain is h3n2 which may cause
more severe illness even more troubling
this year's flu shot is the same one
used in Australia's recent flu season
when it was only 10 percent effective
Australia typically sets a pattern for
what we will face here
dr. pardis sabeti is a professor at
Harvard and an infectious disease expert
who heads up her own research lab good
morning morning so past flu vaccines
range anywhere from ten to sixty percent
effectiveness what do we know about this
year well so that's true you know and on
average about forty percent
effectiveness for the the flu vaccine we
you would mention essentially that in
Australia they did have a poor season
with only 10% the the they have very bad
flu season about five times as many
cases in the previous year and a lot of
that have to do the fact that the
vaccine was only ten percent as you know
effective so it's even low for the flu
and with that there's a lot of people
that are susceptible and because the
formulation the vaccine that they used
in Australia is the same one we're going
to use this year
we expect to see something similar so
what is the challenge why can't we get a
more effective flu vaccine yeah so the
way that vaccines work is that they
basically they're an inactivated or
disabled version of a virus that we
present to our immune system and our
immune system gets to see it to
recognize it to learn it so that if we
ever get a natural you know virus
infection we're ready to respond the
problem with flu and the virus that
causes flu influenza is that it changes
it's very diverse lots of different
strains and it's changing all the time
and so by the time we pick a version of
the virus to make into a vaccine and put
it into production it might take six to
eight months and in that time the virus
might change and so that's an issue and
then also just in the production itself
we have to grow it up and we normally
grow up in
in bird eggs and in that time it also
can mutate in production itself so it
sort of diverged diverges in two
directions so I can ask this because my
son is not watching and he's at school
okay every year he cringes when we have
to go get that flu shot I tell him it's
mandatory we all go in there my husband
myself my son is it worth getting a flu
shot every year if they're not this
effective it's still worth getting a flu
shot I mean I so I believe so you know
personally I always get a flu shot even
ten percent effective is better than
anything and if we all get and a lot of
it has to do with herd immunity the more
people are protected from it the more
other people will also be protected and
so in fact in a year where it's low
effectiveness it's even more important
that everybody gets it affected so that
we can get as much resistant and we
don't allow the virus to thrive and grow
and keep changing so even though the
virus is dead when you get the shot are
you more susceptible to getting cold and
in the flu in general when you get a
shot when you get a shot no I mean I
think that ultimately the shot is
actually giving your immune system a
little test run a practice run so it
should be protective across the board
and it's not only protective from
getting the flu but also the severity of
the flu if you get it so there's
multiple reasons to get it no matter
what next year is the hundredth
anniversary of the flu pandemic that
killed at least 50 million people
worldwide I know you're concerned about
a pandemic yeah no I'm always concerned
that's what keeps keeps me up at night I
worked a lot on Ebola and other viruses
like Lhasa and flu is at the top of the
list of things we should be worried
about because it's so transmissible
because it can move so quickly it's
caused three massive outbreaks in the
20th century including the 1918 cost 50
million deaths you know a significant
portion of the world's population but
the good news is that the same tools
that we can use to stave off seasonal
flu are the same tools that we would use
to stave off the pandemic as well as to
flu or to any virus all right there's a
lot of fun technologies for that we'll
have to leave it there thank you okay
dr. pardis sabeti very much